-Guys, it is the weekend,
and this Sunday
is the Indianapolis 500.
So, between Memorial Day trave
and the Indy 500,
it's a great time for people
who love being stuck in a car.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right --
it's Memorial Day Weekend.
And I read that veterans
and service members
can get discounts
at Outback Steakhouse.
[ Light laughter ]
'Cause nothing says
thank you for putting your lif
on the line
like 10% off a bloomin' onion.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This isn't good --
the Department of Agricultur
just recalled
over 60,000 pounds of raw beef
due to concerns about E. coli.
Anyway, enjoy those Memorial Day
barbecues, everybody.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Have a great one.
Let's get to some news here.
Today, President Trump lef
for a state visit to Japan
then, next week, he's also -
-Whoo! [ Applauds ]
[ Laughter ]
-All right, bloomin' onion
-Hey, now, now.
[ Laughter ]
-President Trump left
for a state visit to Japan
and then, next week, he's also
traveling to the U.K.
Trump's nervous.
He was like,
"First I have to learn Japanese.
Now I have to learn English?
I mean..."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"...who is making my schedule?!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Meanwhile,
the race for 2020 is under way
And I saw that Walmart
invited Bernie Sanders
to its annual
shareholders meeting.
This is very nice.
Walmart told Bernie,
if he doesn't win,
they're gonna hire him
as a greeter.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Welcome to Walmart!
My name is Bernie!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's some sports news.
I heard that the NFL
might start allowing players
to smoke marijuana.
-Yeah!
In response,
NFL players were like,
"Cool. We can't wait to try weed
for the..."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"...very first time."
Now, get this -- officials
in the U.K. say that --
-[ Crying ]
-Oh, guys, you hear that?
It -- It's the news.
It's been so worked up latel
that it must be still awake.
And if it's cool with you guys
I'd just like to take a moment
to put the news to bed.
It's time for "Goodnight, News."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪♪ Good night, news,
good night, news ♪♪
♪♪ Goodnight ♪♪
-[ Softly ] Let's see
if we can put this news to bed
[ Light laughter ]
[ Lullaby plays ]
Goodnight,
23 Democrats now in the race
like so and so, that other guy
and, of course, what's his face.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Applause continues ]
Goodnight, Indy 500.
I've never been so impressed
with someone whose job
is to keep turning left.
[ Applause ]
Goodnight, senior prom.
Stick your head out the window
Now put it back in
and throw up in the limo.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Applause ]
Goodnight, "Game of Thrones.
We have a new King.
He goes by the name
of Sir Poland Spring.
[ Laughter and cheering ]
[ Applause ]
Goodnight, billionaire
paying off
an entire class' student debt --
or as last year's class put it
"Oh, man, what the F?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Applause continues ]
Goodnight, "Bachelorette,"
the fun televised game.
Wish I knew who to root for,
but they all look the same
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally, goodnight,
"Aladdin."
You were granted three wishes.
And now that you're rich,
it's a whole new world,
biatches.
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was "Goodnight, News.
♪♪ Goodnight, news,
goodnight, news ♪♪
♪♪ Goodnight ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, guys,
it's graduation season,
and that means
people are shopping
for that perfect card
for their graduate.
And while there are
some great cards,
there are also
some very unpopular ones
that you should avoid.
I'll show you what I mean.
For instance, this first car
says, "Good luck."
Open it up -- it says, "Paying
your own cellphone bill."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Graduation card.
-Come on.
-This card says,
"Congrats, grad.
You just made
your 68-year-old dad
carry an Ikea couch down
five flights of stairs."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Applause continues ]
And finally, this card says,
"Remember,
if at first you don't succeed,
there's always running
for president."
There you guys have it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally, guys,
it is time for a show of hands
This is where we show
what politicians are reall
doing with their hands
while we think that they'r
focused on giving speeches
Enjoy.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I also believe that
it's turned out to be an asset
that I come from
a different generation.
I maybe don't look the part,
in terms of having
quite as many silver hairs
as you'd expect a presidential
candidate to have.
-But at the same time, it says
that if you are a lower-income
senior citizen,
you will not be able to get...
[ Laughter ]
...the one nutritious meal a day
you now receive through
the Meals on Wheels progra
for the help
you desperately need.
-My grandfather used to say,
"Joey, you're labor from
belt buckle to shoe sole."
That's how he was raised.
[ Laughter ]
And there's no labor leade
who's done a better job.
-And, Mike, we're in there
working hard, right?
And we're getting it done
like very few
have gotten it done before
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're doing really well
as a country.